you could just feel animators walking
off what is this about John it doesn't
have a story
it's the existential crisis so far we've
just got these going in bimbos ass every
location wait a minute we have a bad cop
[Music]
Hey hi um thanks for coming to my place
did the limo get you here was it a nice
riot what is this
no I drove to this by you that is not
money or Burbank for you know whatever
yeah the limo was unbelievable you have
a great home thank you yeah thank you
yeah it's amazing so this first this
first cartoon I wanted to show you as
flesh brothers which you know the
Fleischer brothers mm-hmm during the
famous bimbo character yeah yeah
Oh brings a smile to everybody's face
well yeah he was what happen to everyone
in all over America but no I don't think
so good but I'm still talking and and
the great thing about this cartoon is
that while they were making it so many
of the animators quit that they just
brought in new people who had no idea
how to animate okay so it's like Amazon
animation I mean it's it's great okay
okay good vibe how do you feel so far
excited I'm at the movies I'm at the
picture ha see is this a bimbo your bin
will be in this okay so you centers
I really I really like that title card
up for a while yeah yeah the projection
is just like passed out talk cartoons
anyway I guess this is the whole thing
it's not good you know hope you enjoy it
that was it no I've had it okay there is
a bimbo
a boy and a chicken sure yeah pretty sly
Jesus what's his endgame well I think he
wants to further sex food I'm hoping
that's not so far it has the vibe of a
lot of people quitting so oh yeah and
what's right okay this see cops did we
storyboard cops hang out this ever end
up on a whiteboard no mapped out well I
don't know if you know what police are
like but please hang out near chicken
coops and see if this is the day that
cop would just shoot both of them and
what was the cop upset about that he was
stealing you stealing our chickens but
this cop has nothing better to do look
this is the crime of the time Oh God so
he's running away and there's a chicken
situation so far it feels like and that
this is saying something coming from
this thing we do the plot is light oh no
this is a mr. chase chase cartoon and
then he obviously plays mysteries first
of all that chickens in his anus right
yep that's in bimba yeah that's how I
work no wait if you present procreation
if you put chicken in your anus baby
chicken
[Music]
Dave so now we're in sanitary locked in
as you can see I think that chicken had
LSD on it obviously the plot has taken a
strange turn
what is historic well the story is is
that a guy was stealing chickens and now
he's in a grave okay so maybe they're
[Music]
okay so there's they're pissed about the
henhouse yeah so he's a sinner so he's
got a tone for his sins essentially yeah
oh yeah
well I like that guy hi guys cool you a
man you wanna buy some ghost drugs I
mean so far they're not doing anything
to him except saying this is scary
oh now that's a heightened threat that
is a clear threat Oh bottom white by the
tree that but play there's a lot about
play
[Music]
I mean I would just avoid the graves he
could just feel animators walking off
what is that what is this about John it
doesn't have a story it's an existential
crisis so far we've just got things
going in bimbos ass every location wait
a min we're gonna have a bat come okay
oh my god that's what I beat that one
that one actually looks scary yeah it's
not great it's just I wouldn't steal
chickens we turn it off real light so
now they've guantánamo Tim that's it we
just got out yeah that was a bad move at
100 this is when the chickens kill them
right it's called the chicken kill some
idea this idea this is just like let's
put in the different places and have
things attack them yeah he's a sinner he
took a hint I think that was a what is
that
that's a sickle it's certainly desperate
he's scattered for his life I'm not
frightened of these all I'm like bottoms
there yeah I mean I'm having a good time
these are the bottom goes okay there's a
testicle hello without the graveyard
seen before I'm like this is a good time
yeah this is great everyone's having fun
yeah I mean they synchronize ghosts well
hey now your trio so bindler took
ayahuasca yeah why would this bother you
I mean the hitting I'm genuinely like
exhausted physically firm oh my god well
now it's scary now it is definitely they
they brought her like this could be like
Bohemian Rhapsody but it's a Miss
there's an octopus it's a lot of stuff
coming out to bins oh it was try still
it
president and I'm just shaking the
compound yeah boy they really like
smacking their buds time they come
around when you say the thing that all
the animators put it just doesn't feel
like they all just like I'll do one
thing this is like done by a madman yes
this man this is definitely what I don't
agree with that at all
anyway I hope you learned a lesson I
know how to not end things um well you
know not to steal chickens right yeah
I also really would have loved like it
that one makes me miss other ones which
is again that's saying something like I
just yeah I was just just that was like
a dream that you woke up for me I
remember like thirty percent of it all
right well let's watch it again if
you're not thirty percent no no roll it
[Music]
[Applause]